ich habe gerade eben ein gegeben dass
meine figur 20 ist bist du geistig
komplett hängen geblieben ist 20 mehr
als 18 akinator in der wunderlampe aus
der du kommst warte ich mit dieser
service s kids und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video im hintergrund
sieht den bild was für euch ein bisschen
und vertraut sein dürfte denn das ist
das bild zum akinator es gibt drei
gründe warum ich heute war kein auto
ausprobieren möchte erstens ich komme
gerade direkt vom training und ich bin
richtig fertig ich habe nicht so viel
los jetzt minecraft zu spielen irgendwie
anzustrengen der pvp runde
zweitens ich habe generell auch in
letzter zeit wenig lust auf minecraft
pvp wenn ich jetzt keine aufnahmen
partner habe oder ein gutes format habe
was ich da spiele im drittens ich habe
mir einfach gedacht okay was kann man
für morgen aufnehmen und dann kam mir
akinator in den kopf und ich hab mir
gedacht okay ich probier's mal aus und
die erste runde war gleich richtig
witzig weil er so eine scheiße fragt
dieser trieb ohne witz ich hoffe das
kommt noch mal da können wir uns noch
mal zusammen anschauen uns amüsieren
ich weiß auch heute dass luca akinator
spielt und ich sage das einfach mal so
ganz oft in einerseits möchte ich
natürlich jetzt nicht den eindruck
erwecken dass ich irgendjemanden
irgendwie nach machen oder so aber
andererseits denke ich mir halt auch ein
komplettes spiel mehr spaß macht warum
sollte es mir verboten sein das zu
spielen
ich frage jetzt einfach mal stört euch
und ich frage dich luca stürz dich falls
es so ist dann war das die einzige
letzte folge das entscheidet er bei
einem kommentar
falls es nicht so ist dann können wir
vielleicht noch mal in folge auf dem
vorausgesetzt ist wird lustig aber leute
jetzt lasst uns am anfang als
allererstes erwarten wir mal eine person
die ihr vielleicht kennt also die
zuschauer die wirklich immer dabei sind
jedes video sehen auch jeden block die
dürfen diese person eigentlich kennen
ich sage es mal so okay die ist wie
schon eine weile nicht mehr gesehen ist
am 20
keine küken ok 20 sorry sorry akinator
durch shape lebt eine figur in
deutschland seien figur weiblich nein
wohl deine figur durch youtube berühmt
ich weiß nicht kann man sagen dass du
dich youtube berühmt wurde also klar die
war mal im video dabei aber über
gespannt ob irgendjemand jetzt schon
weiß um wen es geht falls ja dann
schreibt genau jetzt meine kommentare
wenn ihr glaubt zu wissen und wenn's
geht obwohl die figur durch youtube
berühmt
ich sage mal ja ja das sollten sich was
sonst berühmt geworden
es war kein deutsch geworden sein
ich kenne keinen deut mehr durch was
wurde die figur denn sonst berühmt werde
ich das video am ehesten noch durch
youtube also sage ich mal ja wie deine
figur in minecraft war rot 3 mit ja
langes haar das kann ich nicht sagen ich
bin liegt eine figur im haus nein wie
seine figuren mein kräften marken mit
nein
wird die geschichte aus der sicht deiner
figur da geht es schon los die
geschichte aus der sicht meiner figur
diese geste da so what the [ __ ] jung du
stellst folgt dumme fragen wird die
geschichte welche geschichte die
geschichte von der biene maja oder die
geschichte von turkmenistan die
geschichte der welt einmal nein jetzt
geht's so sollte ist eine figur mit
einem opernsänger heiratet ich bin
service ich bin der king auto ich stelle
so schlaue fragen what the [ __ ] alter
mit einem opernsänger verheiratet nein
ich habe ihm den mittelfinger gezeigt
gewählt events zeigen geht das
mittelfinger schweiz macht ihr viel
bergauf lebenden nein mach deine figur
league of legends videos
eher nicht 12 nein also nicht regelmäßig
spielt eine figur war o2 mit nee nee ich
noch nicht call of duty was weist kannst
du nicht wissen und die computer spielt
ich habe gerade eben ein gegeben dass
meine figur 20 ist bist du geistig
komplett hängen geblieben ist 20 mehr
als 18 akinator in der wunderlampe aus
der du kommst was es mit ihrem besten
wieder zurück bei 20 ist mehr als 18
zumindest in der welt wäre ich hier
wohne und lebe erhielt nein nein
leute also echt diese fragen guckt euch
das an erst die frage ist eine figur mit
einem opernsänger verheiratet ja und da
denken wir sich so ok akin autor
vielleicht ist es einfach mal sterben so
die zeit ist gekommen und dann wieder so
ne frage wie hat eine figur bavaro 3
gewonnen wo ist der zusammenhang
zwischen opernsänger und war u 3 also
nicht dass ich etwas verpasst haben
irgend youtube hatten europaserie
geheiratet oder so falls es der fall ist
und schreibt dass man die kommentare
aber das müsste ich eigentlich
mitbekommen haben oder luciano pavarotti
hat eine figur etwas mit sex zu tun ist
es überhaupt die offizielle akinator ich
habe einfach die ersten web page
ausgesucht was ja hat sich schon mal sex
gab in ihrem leben oder was soll heißen
mit sex zu tun hat sich sex aber ihre
youtube channel
junge junge junge ja ist aber ja ja ist
eine figur schüchtern weiß nicht eher
dünn
weiß nicht ja
nein ja als false false false leute
manche von euch haben es vielleicht
schon geahnt die figur dies heute ging
die war der liebe und er kann einfach
auf felsen hd ich frage mich wo ich ein
fehlgeleitet haben könnte vielleicht war
es an der stelle wo er danach gefragt
habe ob die figuren pvp meister ist wie
gesagt so gut schreibt mit eurem
feedback in die kommentare
ich wollte eigentlich gar nicht akinator
so wirklich let's play aber da habe ich
die erste runde gespielt und die war
einfach so witzig weil er so viel
scheiße fragt dieser typ ich finde es
persönlich lustig das macht mir einfach
gerade mehr spaß also einfach ein
kräftiger ja das war's vom heutigen
video dann sehen uns in der nächsten
folge wieder last einen daumen nach
unten
nein macht sich bis dahin